der Krieg in der Ukraine ist ein echtes
Drama nicht nur für die Ukraine die
natürlich Opfer einer kriminellen
Invasion sind sondern auch für Russland
selbst egal wie sehr Putins Regime
versucht den Menschen etwas anderes weiß
zu machen zudem wirtschaftlichen
Verlusten die wir hier auf visualpolitik
bereits besprochen haben kommen noch die
militärischen Verluste hinzu die noch
bedeutender sind zum Zeitpunkt der
Erstellung dieses Videos hat der muss
danach westlichen Schätzungen seit
Kriegsbeginn über 200.000 Opfer zu
beklagen das heißt die Gesamtzahl an
Soldaten die getötet wurden oder Kopf
und wie sind weil sie verwundet wurden
oder als Gefangene gehalten werden um
euch eine Vorstellung davon zu geben das
ist zehnmal so viel in einem einzigen
Kriegsjahr als alle Opfer inklusive der
Verwundeten die die USA in zwei
Jahrzehnten Afghanistan kriegt zu
beklagen hatten außerdem werden viele
Soldaten überleben lebenslange
körperlich und psychische Schäden
davontragen dies alles scheint jedoch
keinen Grund für den Gremmel zu sein den
Krieg zu überdenken und wisst ihr was
die Wahrheit ist dass wir nicht allzu
überrascht sein sollten
in der Vergangenheit war das russische
Militär nicht gerade dafür bekannt das
Leben seines Soldaten zu schätzen oder
zu schützen entweder aus mangelnder
Sensibilität oder Humanität oder aus
Mangel an Mitteln nahm es Moskau ohne
mit der Wimper zu zucken immer in Kauf
seine Feldzüge in einen Fleischwolf für
die eigenen Leute zu verwandeln ein
Beispiel dafür ist der zweite Weltkrieg
in dem mehr als 8 bis 10 Millionen
sowjetisches Soldaten starben davon
waren mehr als sechseinhalb Millionen
Russen und zweieinhalb Millionen Ukraine
und ja es stimmt Putin Russland ist
nicht die Sowjetunion aber der Krieg in
der Ukraine hat uns gezeigt dass ich an
dieser Mentalität in der Praxis nicht
viel geändert hat Russland ist bei der
Verfolgung seine militärischen Ziele
immer noch bereit einen sehr hohen Blut
soll zu zahlen
all dies wird durch das Fehlen einer
funktionierenden politischen Opposition
und eine apathische Bevölkerung
begünstigt diese ist schon seit Jahren
den intensiven Propagandakampagne des
Regimes ausgesetzt Kritiker des Regimes
werden brutal unterdrückt alles ist
gleichgeschaltet Russland fehlt also
jegliche Art politische und
gesellschaftlicher Selbstreflexion und
damit elementare Fähigkeiten der
Fehlerkorrektur es ist also auch
weiterhin unwahrscheinlich dass der
Verlust von Menschenleben ein großes
Hindernis für Putin darstellen würden
[Musik]
tatsächlich glauben viele Analysten dass
er noch einige hunderttausend weitere
Opfer zur Schlachtbank führen kann ohne
das Regime wirklich zu gefährden und das
alles wird natürlich die Frage auf wenn
den so ist wie könnte Russland dann auf
dem politischen unitärischen
Schlachtfeld überhaupt aufgehalten
werden was sind seine Schwachpunkte wenn
menschliche Verluste Putin nicht allzu
sehr zu belasten scheinen nur der
Schlüssel liegt in der Ausrüstung
Bewaffnung und Logistik in Dingen die
Panzern Artillerie Luftwaffe und
Luftabwehr Aufklärung Depots
Versorgungslinien Lastwagen und Zügen es
ist nämlich die eine Sache eine Menge
Menge an die Frauen zu schicken aber
wenn sie nicht gut ausgerüstet sind und
laufend mit ausreichend Munition
probierend und Informationen beliefert
werden kann das Ergebnis katastrophal
sein vor allem wenn Sie es mit einem
relativ modernen agierenden
ausgebildeten und ausgerüsteten Gegner
zu tun haben dann werden sie nämlich
egal wie viele es sind zu nichts anderem
als purem Schlacht viel und Putin könnte
statt seiner hippen E-Mobil machen per
SMS einfach nur die Tore der russischen
Schweine Stelle in Richtung Ukraine
öffnen das hätte nämlich denselben
Effekt okay natürlich ist dieses Bild
stark überspitzt aber im Grunde spiegelt
ist das Endziel der Strategie der
Ukraine und ihre Verbündeten wieder in
diesem Video erklären wir euch daher
genau wie die russischen militärischen
Fähigkeiten reduziert werden können und
zwar sowohl auf dem Schlachtfeld als
auch außerhalb wieso waren die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte den Russen
bisher überlegen und werden Sie diese
Überlegenheit auch weiterhin behaupten
können welche sind die spezifischen
Schwachstellen der Russen an denen man
sie gezielt schlagen kann und wie
konkret wirken sich die Sanktionen auf
die Rüstungsindustrie und deren
Schwachstellen aus wäre es vielleicht
möglich den Aggressor Russland dadurch
am Ende ein für alle Mal entschärfen und
auch nuklear entwaffnen zu können könnte
das kriegslösterne Imperium nach dem
Vorbild Deutschlands oder Japans
irgendwann in eine friedliches
prosperierendes und mit sich selbst und
seinen Nachbarn zufriedenes Land
verwandelt werden so dass von russischen
Boden nie wieder ein mit Krieg ausgehen
kann in diesem Video werden wir all
diese Fragen von Grund auf angehen zuvor
muss ich jedoch noch etwas Wichtiges in
eigener Sache anbringen in früheren
Videos habe ich bereits eine Sprache
gebracht wie wichtig für den
Weiterbetrieb unserer arbeitssponsoren
sind tatsächlich helfen sie uns zurück
zwei Drittel unserer Kosten zu decken
und das ist schon ein Wort kurz um ohne
Sponsoren gäbe es visualpolitik in
dieser Form nicht natürlich versuchen
wir immer ausschließlich mit Sponsoren
zusammen zu arbeiten die seriös sind und
denjenigen unserer Zuschauer die sich
für die im Angebot interessieren einen
Mehrwert bringen dazu prüfen wir jede
Sponsor vorab lassen uns
Hintergrundinformationen zum Angebot zu
kommen und besorgen uns diese auch von
Dritten unabhängigen Stellen einige
Fragen haben wir aufgrund der
Erkenntnisse die wir vorab gewinnen
konnten deshalb auch abgelehnt aber
bitte fragt es nicht danach es würde
nicht der Fairness eines ehrbaren
Kaufmanns entsprechen dies öffentlich zu
machen wer von uns in die Wüste
geschickt wird ist schon gestraft genug
vor rund zwei Wochen haben wir für einen
sponsorwerbung gemacht der das
Nahrungsergänzungsmittel AG1 anbietet
selbstverständlich haben wir uns auch
hier im Vorfeld ausgiebig über das
Produkt den Anbieter und die Erfahrungen
von Kunden informiert und sind zum
Ergebnis gelangt dass wir dieses
Sponsoring ohne Problem mit unserem
Gewissen vereinbaren können gesagt getan
ja als dann aber die ersten Kommentare
zu dieser Werbung oder dem Video
auftauchten haben wir ein wenig gestaunt
von vielen wurden wir dabei auf ein
Video des ZDF youtube-kanals besser
hingewiesen indem Agon regelrecht
verrissen wurde okay wenn das jetzt von
irgendeinem XY Influenza gekommen wäre
hätte ich es beiseite gewischt aber ein
Video von ZDF mit 600.000 aufrufen und
16000 likes da musste ich erstmal
schlucken haben wir bei unserer
Produktrecherche etwa irgendwas ultra
wichtiges übersehen also schnell das ZDF
Video aufmachen und alles noch mal
prüfen zur Not kann man den Vertrag ja
kündigen und das werbesegment wieder
rausschneiden aber trotzdem wie peinlich
naja ihr müsst wissen ich habe seit 25
Jahren keinen Fernseher mehr und
irgendwie beruht mein Bild von der
Qualität und Seriosität
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks immer
noch auf dem was mich in der Zeit davor
geprägt hat ja ich weiß dass da eine
ordentliche Portion naiver Ignoranz und
nostalgische Hoffnung mit schwingt auch
ich will wohl nicht wirklich wahrhaben
zu was ich Deutschlands größter medialer
Komplex mittlerweile entwickelt hat aber
genug der Vorrede ich habe das Video
ganz unvoreingenommen aufgemacht und
höre dann gebannt hin was die guten
Gebühren finanzierten Kollegen zu sagen
haben und was dann kommt ist für mich
einen wechselbar der Gefühle zum einen
bin ich erleichtert nein wir müssen den
Werbepartnern nicht aus dem Video
schneiden zum anderen aber mal wieder
maßlos enttäuscht enttäuscht darüber was
das ZDF da mal wieder veröffentlicht hat
und das so viele Zuschauer auf derartig
billige Manipulation hereinfallen und
billig meine ich sicher nicht im Sinne
der Produktionskosten da lag in
irgendeiner Ecke beim ZDF wohl noch eine
Kopie des uns solchen framing Handbuchs
herum und ich dachte das Thema wäre
längst durch nach all dem für den
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk ober
peinlichen Enthüllungen versteht mich
nicht falsch mir geht's hier nicht um
pauschale Verurteilung oder darum dass
hier gezielt unabhängige Content
Produzenten geframt werden die nicht von
öffentlichen Gebühren leben können mir
geht's auch darum wie un seriös dieses
Video ist wenn es auch obersteriöster
herkommt dies wird auch offensichtlich
wenn man etwas tiefer in die Kommentare
einsteigt in denen sich manche wirklich
kritisch mit dem Video auseinandersetzen
das Fazit man wollte dieses Produkt
einfach schlecht machen um jeden Preis
am besten als gesundheitsschädliches
schlangenöl von Kapitalisten aus
überseebrandmarken nur haben die nicht
wirkenden und vorbildlichen Kollegen
halt leider nichts wirklich
stichhaltiges gegen LG one gefunden also
wurde alles Erdenkliche aus dem
Zusammenhang gerissen und dann so zur
Zimmer das eine Möglichkeit schlechter
Eindruck von diesem Produkt entsteht
nach dem Motto so viel Dreck werfen wie
möglich irgendwas bleibt schon beim
Zuschauer hängen wie sie später
herausgestellt hat hatte Hersteller den
Redakteuren eine ganze Reihe relevanter
Studien zur Verfügung gestellt sie haben
sich jedoch nur zwei herausgepickt die
in ihr Bild posten und dann im Netz noch
ein paar weitere gefunden die sich nicht
direkt auf das Produkt bezogen um es
noch mal klar zu betonen dies soll keine
Pauschalkritik am ZDF und auch nicht an
dessen YouTube-Kanal besser sein ich
kenne die übrigen Videos dort nicht
vielleicht bin ich da auch etwas
altmodisch aber wenn man sich schon mit
dem Gütesiegel des
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks
schmückt und von den Gebühren der
Allgemeinheit finanziert wird sollte man
Ideologie und Sensationslust
unterdrücken und viel mehr einer
Sorgfaltspflicht genügen der dieses
Video eindeutig nicht gerecht wird trotz
seines sicher üppigen Produktionsbudgets
hat das ZDF nämlich auch einfach mal
darauf verzichtet eine Laboruntersuchung
des Inhalt in Auftrag zu geben dabei
habe ich keine 3 Minuten gebraucht um
herauszufinden dass unabhängige
Ernährung Journal im Bett genau die ist
schon getan haben und das Ergebnis war
immer das Zeug ist unbedenklich und
gesund seriöse Ernährung Journalismus
wäre es gewesen sich wirklich objektiv
und wissenschaftlich mit den
Inhaltsstoffen auseinanderzusetzen zum
Beispiel Hinblick auf Dosierung
Verfügbarkeit und tatsächliche
Studienlage und sorry einfach zu
behaupten man könnte Angie one durch
einen Apfel ersetzen ist absoluter Unfug
ebenso unpassend ist das natürlich
richtige Argument ein sich vollkommen
und perfekt gesund ernährender Mensch
würde keinen Nahrungsergänzungsmittel
brauchen denn erstens ernährt sich der
überwiegende Teil der Bevölkerung alles
andere als perfekt gesund und zwar aus
den vielfältigsten gründen und zweitens
haben mittlerweile zahlreiche Studien
gezeigt dass ein signifikanter Teil der
Bevölkerung z.B unzureichende Vitamin D
Spiegel aufweist insbesondere ein Region
mit geringerer Sonneneinstrahlung oder
längeren Wintermonaten
Nahrungsergänzungsmittel pauschal als
nutzlos abzustempeln ist daher
eigentlich schon grenzwertig und seriös
naja immerhin wurde ein
Ernährungswissenschaftler befragt und da
dieser erstmal eigentlich nichts konkret
schlimmes über das Produkt sagen konnte
wurde die Überdosis Karte gezogen ja
wenn man bestimmte Bestandteile
überdosiert dann kann dies
gesundheitsschädlich sein was für eine
Erkenntnis natürlich können ganz viele
gesunde Dinge schaden wenn man sie stark
überdosiert deswegen gibt der Hersteller
ja an wie viel am tag man nehmen soll
und er ist dabei auch noch meilenweit im
sicheren Bereich ein Beispiel um beim
vom ZDF als gefährlich gebrandmarkten
biotine über das empfundene Tageslimit
zu kommen müsste man 66 Tagesrationen LG
one auf einmal schlucken tja ich denke
dass jemand der zwei Monats Packungen
trocken in sich hinein kippt oder 17
Liter auf einmal trinkt ganz andere
Probleme hat dann wird noch darauf herum
geritten man könne viele Bestandteile
von auch einzeln kaufen und dies wäre
dann viel billiger klar ist lG und ein
Produkt das einen Preis hat und man
würde in der Summe wohl weniger bezahlen
wenn man jeden Inhaltsstoff einzeln als
Brausetablette oder Pulver erwerben
würde aber es gibt nun mal Leute die
keine Lust und auch keine Zeit haben
sich alle 75 Inhaltsstoffe einzeln
zusammen zu suchen und dann auch noch
die jeweiligen Mengenverhältnisse
manuell so auszutarieren und
aufzubereiten dass eine optimale
Bioverfügbarkeit erreicht wird ja liebe
besser ist Redakteure Newsflash Menschen
sind doch tatsächlich dazu bereit für
mehr convenience Zeitersparnis
Verlässlichkeit und auch Lifestyle etwas
mehr Geld zu bezahlen deswegen kaufen
manche eben lieber Apple Produkte mit
ihrem gepamperten Ökosystem andere
bevorzugen nur ein gerootetes Android
okay ich könnte jetzt noch ein ganzes
Video lang aufzählen was alles an diesem
ZDF Video oberfaul ist aber wir haben
heute zum Glück noch viel wichtigere
Themen zu besprechen also lasst euch
bitte nicht von derartigen grenzwertigen
wenn nach unschuldigter herkommenden
Beiträgen in die Irre führen wir lassen
es auch nicht und deswegen sagen wir uns
jetzt erst recht schreibt uns ruhig was
ihr über dieses Thema denkt wir haben
euch in der Videobeschreibung auch eine
offizielle Stellungnahme des Sponsors
verlinkt übrigens für diese kritisch
Auseinandersetzung mit dem ZDF Video hat
uns LG1 keinen einzigen Cent bezahlt das
ist einfach eine Frage der medialen und
ja auch kaufmännischen Ehre es ärgert
einen eben schon ein bisschen wenn so
viel Gebühren finanziert hat unsere
verzapft wird schließlich wollen wir
doch alle seriöse und ehrliche
öffentlich-rechtliche Medien oder und
deswegen kommt jetzt vollkommen
gebührenfrei die Werbung LG wollen
unseres neuen Sponsors athletic green
schließlich geht es ja nicht darum dass
man unbedingt leistungsfähig sein muss
sondern dass man leistungsfähig sein
will weil Leistung eben Spaß macht nicht
wahr der Schlüssel dazu ist allerdings
geistige und körperliche Fitness und vor
allem eine gute Routine Routinen sind
essentiell um unseren Alltag zu
strukturieren und Körper und Geist auf
Kurs zu halten bei mir sieht diese so
aus dass ich als Nachteule nach dem
Aufstehen und vor dem Frühstück erstmal
meinen Kreislauf und meine Mitochondrien
in Schwung bringen muss ideal ist da für
mich ein wenig Sport hauptsächlich
Krafttraining allerdings kommt davor
noch etwas anderes wichtiges der Körper
will mit Wasser und wichtigen
Nährstoffen versorgt werden allerdings
ohne ihn zu belasten und an dieser
Stelle kommt LG1 von Atlantic Greens ins
Spiel mit seinen 75 hochwertigen
Inhaltsstoffen Vitamin Mineralstoffen
Botanicals und Bakterienkulturen gibt es
einem genau für diese aktivierende
Morgenroutine den umfassenden
nährstoffkickt und aktiv und unbelastet
in den Tag zu starten das tolle daran es
ist sehr einfach in der Anwendung aber
seine Mikronährstoffe wurden aus echten
natürlichen Nahrungsmitteln wie Erbsen
Soja oder Chlorella geworden außerdem
sind sie in hoher Bioverfügbarkeit
vorhanden so dass sie besonders gut vom
Körper aufgenommen werden können tja und
darüber hinaus schmeckt es auch noch gut
mir zu wenig aber wartet hier kommt der
Beweis
eine einzige Portion Angie wollen das
heißt ein Messlöffel in 250 ml Wasser
versorgt mein Körper nach dem Aufstehen
mit vielen wichtigen Nährstoffen und
dann geht's gleich raus in den Garten um
mit reichlich Sonnenlicht und Bewegung
man in circa dianen Rhythmus und
Energiestoffwechsel in Schwung zu
bringen und den Serotoninspiegel
anzuheben dadurch bin ich automatisch
wacher besser gelaunt und stelle meine
innere Uhr ein und tagsüber
leistungsfähig für das recherchieren
schreiben und Filme zu sein und abends
trotz aller Krisen dieser Welt über die
ich dabei nachdenken und Berichten
musste gut einschlafen zu können passend
dazu bietet Athletics unsere Community
ein exklusives früheres Angebot wenn du
über den Link in der Videobeschreibung
gehst erhältst du bei Abschluss eines
monatlichen Abbruchs einen kostenlosen
Jahresvorrat an Vitamin D3 und K2 und 5
praktische LG one travel Packs für
unterwegs gratis neukunden erhalten
außerdem das LG one welcome Cat
inklusive schicker Aufbewahrungsdose und
einen praktischen Shaker zur Monats
Packung dazu ach und vor dem Abo
brauchst du auch keine Angst zu haben du
kannst es nämlich jederzeit pausieren
kündigen oder den unterrhythmus nach
Belieben anpassen aber das ist noch
nicht alles um dir die Entscheidung noch
leichter zu machen bietet LG1 eine 90
Tage Geld zurück Garantie stellst du
also nach drei Monaten fest dass es doch
nicht zu Dir passt bekommst du das Geld
für die erste Bestellung einfach wieder
zurück ohne dass du dafür irgendwelche
Gründe angeben musst also worauf wartet
ihr noch probiert LG won doch einfach
mal aus und bringt eure Ernährung und
Routine auch auf Vordermann und schreibt
mir danach hier in den angepinnten
Kommentar wie eure Erfahrungen waren so
und nun lasst uns endlich die Ärmel
hochkrempeln und loslegen wie könnte man
das russische Militär Imperium
entschärfen aufgepasst
die Entschärfung des Riesen
[Musik]
es ist kein Geheimnis dass die Verluste
an russischen militärgeräte in der
Ukraine für die vermeintlich zwei
stärkste Militär Macht der Welt
verheerend sind und während die Ukraine
von vielen Ländern mit Waffen und
Munition geliefert wird ist Russland
diesen Krieg praktisch auf sich alleine
gestellt natürlich gibt es ein paar
wenige Ausnahmen wie Iran und Nordkorea
aber dazu später mehr ich werde euch ein
paar Daten geben damit ihr eine
Vorstellung davon bekommt spreche bis
Mitte Dezember hat der Russland nach
Angaben des britischen
Verteidigungsministeriums 4.500
gepanzerte Fahrzeuge verloren darunter
1800 Panzer außerdem waren 63 Flugzeuge
70 Hubschrauber 150 und 12 Kriegsschiffe
und mehr als 600 Artillerie Systeme
nicht mehr einsatzfähig pro Tag feuerten
die Russen bis zu 20.000 Artillerie
Geschosse ab oder Verbrauch von
Präzisionsraketen überstieg bei weitem
die Produktionskapazität ein Thema das
übrigens auch die Verbündeten der
Ukraine in gewissen Maße betrifft die
Ukraine verbraucht ihre Munition
schneller als die USA und NATO sie
produzieren können der Unterschied ist
das nicht nur die USA und andere
NATO-Länder Waffen und Munition und die
Ukraine liefern können sondern auch
Nachschub in anderen Ländern gekauft und
dann an das ukrainische Militär
geliefert wird zwei Faktoren spielen
hier die Hauptrolle erstens ist das
westliche steckbuch sehr dick und
zweitens können die industriellen
Kapazitäten in relativ kurzer Zeit
ausgebaut werden das sind zwei
ausschlaggebende Vorteile über die die
Russen heute nicht verfügen und
sicherlich erwartet auch niemand
zumindest ernsthaft dass Sie sie in
naher Zukunft erlangen werden die
Fähigkeiten des Landes militärische
Ausrüstung herzustellen sind in den
letzten Monaten stark geschwächt worden
was zum Teil auf internationale Sanktion
zurückzuführen ist
viele westliche Militärs Analysten sind
der Meinung dass der Krieg aus Mangel an
Waffen enden könnte wenn Russland seine
Rüstungsindustrie nicht in Gang hält
aber wie wahrscheinlich ist es dass
diese Analysen tatsächlich zutreffen und
diese Strategie wirklich aufgeht Wörter
Russland in einem Zermürbungskrieg er
gewinnen oder er verlieren nur der Kreml
scheint an ersteres zu glauben aber ist
das wirklich realistisch es gibt
mindestens zwei wichtige Gründe die
dafür sprechen das Russland ist in den
kommenden Monaten sehr schwer haben wird
seine militärop eration mit Waffen zu
versorgen und zwar noch viel höherem
Maße als sie es bisher erleben dürfen
fangen wir also an der erste Grund sind
natürlich die Exportbeschränkungen nach
Russland die wird bereits
berichtet haben sind sowohl die zivile
als auch die militärische Industrie
Russlands ineffizient sie ist im
allgemeinen technologisch veraltet und
abhängig von anderen fortgeschrittenen
Ländern aus diesem Grund war das Verbot
Schlüssel Elemente für die russische
Industrie zu exportieren eine der
wichtigsten Speerspitzen der westlichen
Strategie
dabei geht es nicht nur um rein
militärische Technologien sondern vor
allem um sogenannte dual use Ausrüstung
das heißt Spitzentechnologie die nicht
nur für den Kriegseinsatz geeignet ist
aber dafür durchaus genutzt werden
könnte wie zum Beispiel fortschrittliche
Halbleiter Optik und Zensuren und sogar
Software
diese Art von Sanktionen für zu
Produktionsausfällen aufgrund mangelnde
Nachschubs was nicht nur zu einer
geringeren Produktionskapazität führt es
bedeutet auch dass die Gerätschaft die
das Werk verlässt egal ob neu oder
überholen mit einer viel einfacheren
Technologie ausgestattet ist wollt ihr
ein paar Beispiele seht euch mal das
hier an Russlands Panzer Plan man nehme
einen 60 Jahre alten t-62 installiere
eine neue Optik und schicke ihn in die
Ukraine damit er in die Luft gejagt wird
der russische panzerhersteller oral
vagonsa Wort holt bis zu 800 t 62 aus
der Langzeitlagerung und rüstet einige
von ihnen mit dem analogen
wärmebildziele Gerät aus das eine
Generation neuer ist als das bisherige
Zielfernrohr des t62 zusammengefasst man
nehme Panzer aus dem frühen 60er Jahren
verpasse ihnen neue optische Sensoren
und ein paar andere Dinge und dann nach
diesem Facelift geht ab in den Kampf
gegen die Ukraine aber das ist noch
nicht alles auch vor den modernsten
Panzern wie dem T-80 oder t-14
angeblichen der russischen Armee braucht
sich die Ukraine nicht sonderlich zu
fürchten im Vorteil falls Russland
wirklich so leichtsinnig sein sollte T14
armata Panzer an die Front zu schicken
wäre dies eine sehr gute Nachricht für
die ukrainische Armee denn der T14
armata stellt einen nicht
funktionsfähiges und unfertiges
Waffensystem da mit einem
problematischen Motor der die ständige
Anwesen eines Teams von werkstechnikern
an der Front erfordert der armata ist
der Inbegriff für alles was am
russischen Militär oberfaul ist groß
mollig grandiose Pläne verunt heute
Milliarden Abhängigkeit von westliche
Technologie und als Ergebnis ein
dysfunktionales Waffensystem dass die
Russen selbst verachten oder zumindest
die eine Russen die einen Einblick in
den russischen militärischen
industriellen Komplex haben
armata ist inzwischen wirklich zu einem
Spitznamen geworden der entweder ein
langes Bauprojekt oder einen
vergeblichen Versuch bezeichnet etwas
komplett von 0 aus zu erschaffen fakt
ist dass der t-14 ein Prototyp bleiben
wird der keine Chance auf einem
Massenproduktion hat Roman zur komarchow
russische verteidigungsexperte in weiten
Teil der Öffentlichkeit herrscht immer
noch die Vorstellung dass die
Herstellung von Prototypen genauso
komplexer sogar noch komplexer sei als
die Massenproduktion die kollektive
Intuition er liegt gleich dem Glauben
die Massenproduktion sei ein Kinderspiel
sobald es einen funktionierenden
Prototyp gebe aber das ist eine völlig
falsche und viel geleitet Vorstellung
die Serienproduktion ist eine um
Größenordnung und komplexere technische
logistische organisatorische und
finanzielle Herausforderung als die
Herstellung eines Prototyps tatsächlich
ist selbst das Testen eines Prototyps
und die Feinabstimmung zum Endprodukt
ein viel komplexerer Prozess als die
Herstellung eines oder mehrere
Prototypen an sich der erwartet wird
dabei nicht nur nicht in Serie
produziert sondern ist noch nicht einmal
fertig getestet
das Hauptproblem des armata ist der
Motor in den 1930er Jahren wurde das
sowjetische V2 Diesel für die
Panzertypen T-34 kv1 KV2 und is1
entwickelt auf diesen basierenden alle
nachfolgenden sowjetischen und
russischen dieselpanzermotoren ob im
T-72 oder in den ps1-3 bei allen handelt
es sich um Weiterentwicklungen und
Optimierungen des 90 Jahre alten V2
Designs sie heißen v84 v92 UDT 20 und 29
das alles ist eigentlich erstmal gut
auch wenn es dem technischen line ultra
induktiv erscheint denn ein altes
hochgradig optimiert ist und dadurch
zuverlässiges Aggregat unseren gesamter
Produktionsprozess ist einem neuen
weniger erprobten erstmal Haus hoch
überlegen jetzt hört euch aber mal die
Geschichte an warum im armata eigentlich
eine andere eine neuer Motor eingesetzt
wird ihr werdet aus dem Staunen nicht
mehr herauskommen
[Applaus]
alles fängt damit an dass die russische
Firma Trans Diesel Anfang der 90er Jahre
ein neues Diesel-Aggregat für Öl und
gasverdichterstationen entwickelte das
Kuriose dabei diese Neuentwicklung
namens
a85-3a basierte auf einem panzermotor
den deutschen Simmering sla1 der schon
im Tiger 1 und 2 verbaut wurde aber das
nur am Rande es handelt sich also quasi
um einen panzermotor die Leistungsdaten
des A85 sind gegenüber dem alten v92
eigentlich nicht schlecht mit seinen
exförmigen Zylindern erreicht er eine
maximal Leistung von 1800 PS und bringt
auch ein Normalbetrieb noch 1500 PS
diese mehr Leistung kommt jedoch zu
einem hohen Preis der Motor wiegt 1.550
Kilo das sind 500 kg mehr als der v92
schuld daran ist natürlich auch die
mangelnde Optimierung er wurde einfach
viel zu wenig getestet und in der Praxis
erprobt als Trans Diesel diesen neuen
Motor auf verschiedenen Ausstellungen
zeigte war daher niemand sonderlich
beeindruckt was sollte man also mit
diesem Ladenhüter machen sollte man
wirklich zugeben dass alles für die Katz
war nein was für ein Gesichtsverlust
wäre das gewesen nur zum Glück hatten
ein paar befreundete Manager in der
Leitung des russischen panzerherstellers
Ural vagonsa Wort eine tolle Idee wie
man das Problem dieses Motors auf eine
ganz besondere Weise lösen könnte sie
nahmen ihn und entwickelten einfach
einen neuen Panzer um ihn herum geboren
war der Tee 14 armata
[Musik]
tja genau so läuft es im militärischen
industriellenkomplex der Russen alles
wie geschmiert und genau aus diesem
Grund ist der Motor des armata schwer
komplex und unzuverlässig außerdem hat
er ganz andere Abmessungen als der
russische Standardmotor v92 der Einbau
eines v292 in den armata einschließlich
des Getriebes ist ohne tiefgreifende
Eingriffe in die Struktur des Panzers
nicht möglich und aus ähnlichen Gründen
können übrigens auch die Jahr MZ 880
Motoren der Jahres double Werke nicht
verwendet werden am Ende wurde daher
beschlossen den A85 im armata
beizubehalten der Cloud dabei mit diesem
Motor lässt sich der Panzer eigentlich
nur unter der permanenten Aufsicht in
der Gruppe von Technikern und
Ingenieuren zufriedenstellen bewegen um
euch eine Vorstellung zu ermöglichen
damit ein derart komplexes Aggregat
ausreifen kann muss es in vielen tausend
oder 10.000 Stückzahlen produziert und
auch draußen eingesetzt werden nur so
sammelt man ausreichend Erfahrungen und
Feedback die dann in die Verbesserung
der Produktion einfließen können
aufgrund der allgemeinen geringen
Nachfrage nach dem 85 hat es Trans
Diesel aber auch nach über 30 Jahren
nicht geschafft seine Massenproduktion
zufrieden stellt in den Griff zu
bekommen und bei oral-bargonsawo sieht
es nicht besser aus es gibt bis heute
keine Fertigungsstraße für die
Massenproduktion des armata die Halle
ist fertig aber es gibt keine Maschinen
denn die russische Militärindustrie ist
vollständig von westlichen
fertigungsmaschinenabhängig vor allem
von deutschen aber auch von koreanischen
japanischen und tschechischen nach dem
ersten russischen Angriff auf die
Ukraine im Jahr 2014 wurde bereits die
Lieferung moderner westliche
Produktionsmaschinen für Waffen im
Rahmen der ersten Sanktionen
unterbrochen westliche Maschinen mit den
armata Panzer hergestellt werden sollten
wurden also nie geliefert daher wird die
manuelle Stück Produktion des C14 in
einer halb operativen versuchswerkstatt
durchgeführt und das Ergebnis sieht dann
so aus
aramata das Story ist over als der T14
armata Panzer 2015 bei der Parade zum 9
mai dem Tag des Sieges sensationell
enthüllt wurde brach er peinlicherweise
auf seiner Probefahrt vor Tausenden von
Schaulustigen zusammen das hatte eine
Vorahnung sein sieben Jahre später kann
man mit Sicherheit sagen dass die
armatas Terry vorbei ist die Probleme
hören beim Motor aber noch lange nicht
auf ein Desaster ist auch die Panzerung
die das wolgograder mit der logi-werk
für russische Panzerfahrzeuge geliefert
die Firma wurde bereits 2018 für
Insolvenz erklärt und der Eigentümer
wird international gesucht weil er ein
Darlehen in Höhe von 85 Millionen Dollar
Verantwortung und 6,2 Milliarden Rubel
ins Ausland verschafft hat auch das ist
wieder typisch und es stellt sich daher
die Frage wie der Kampfeinsatz des Marta
in der Ukraine überhaupt aussehen sollte
nur nach Vorstellung des Geheimnis
sollte armata Panzer auf dem
Schlachtfeld t72 und T-90 Panzer
unterstützen indem er mit seinem
überliegenden zensorik Ziele ausmacht
etwas was die Ukraine mit billigen
Drohnen viel besser hinkriegen aber dazu
später mehr denn beim Armada stellt sich
schnell an die Frage wie die
Kommunikation zwischen den
Panzerbesatzungen sicher und schnell
funktioniert soll russische Panzer haben
nämlich keine digitalen
gesichtsführungs- und kommandosysteme
einschließlich moderner digitaler
Funkgeräte für die Daten Übertragung
alles wird über sprachfunk gesteuert
wenn die russischen Panzer den Feind mit
ihrem Radar sehen können dann gilt dies
auch umgekehrt westliche Radargeräte
können jedoch die sende Leistung je nach
Nähe des Zieles reduzieren um ihren
Ursprung besser zu verbergen hat jedoch
beschlossen dass dies nicht so wichtig
ist weswegen die russischen Radare immer
mit voller Pulle Leistung arbeiten und
genau aus diesem Grund sind russische
Panzer im wahrsten Worten hervorragende
Zielscheiben dabei können alles Sensoren
und empfindlichen elektronischen
Komponenten des armata schon durch
kleinkalibriges Feuer einfach zerstört
werden das ist durchaus normal aber eben
deshalb ist es notwendig sich bedeckt zu
halten und eine ausgezeichnete
Ersatzteile Logistik mitsamt
hervorragenden Technikern in der
Hinterhand zu haben der armata kann in
der Ukraine also noch eine einzige Weise
sinnvoll eingesetzt werden um Propaganda
Videos zu drehen putin ist wunderbar
Panzer musste dabei immer in den
hinteren Linien bleiben um nicht in
direkte Kämpfer verwickelt zu werden
oder den Ukraine in die Hände zu fallen
ja aber wenn dies gelingt werden wir
alle diese Videos als Beweis für die
reife fortgeschrittene russischer Waffen
bewundern können aber mal im Ernst in
Wirklichkeit illustriert uns das
Beispiel armata hervorragend vor Welt
gigantischen und eigentlich
unüberwindbaren strukturellen
Herausforderungen das russische Militär
heute steht um euch eine Vorstellung zu
geben über was wir hier reden damit der
armata irgendeinen Vorteil im Kampf
bringen kann müssten 200 Fabriken die an
der Produktion vom Almata beteiligt sind
neu aufgebaut und umstrukturiert werden
dies wäre die einzige Möglichkeit damit
Russland eine moderne Plattform für
schwere gepanzerte Raupenfahrzeuge
bekommt um es mit westlichen
Gegenstücken die jetzt an die Ukraine
geliefert werden aufnehmen zu können und
damals selbst in Moskau weiß dass dies
ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit ist hat man
uralvagonsabwort vorgegeben statt des
t-14 die Kriegsproduktion von t90m
Panzern und die kontinuierliche
Modernisierung der T-72 zu priorisieren
der Traum vom armata ist damit
ausgeträumt auch ein anderes russisches
Panzerwerk und Transport hat sich
deswegen vor allem auf die
Wiederbelebung Modernisierung Alter
landwaffensysteme festgelegt es geht
dabei um die in Depots vor sich
hinrockenen t 72 Panzer aber auch neuere
80 BVM oder Toss 1A kettenwerfer dabei
treten jedoch schon den nächsten
Probleme zu Tage die russische Industrie
ist nicht in der Lage moderne Elektronik
herzustellen und wie Analysen von
erbeuterter russische Ausrüstung in der
Ukraine zeigen verwenden russische
Waffen massenhaft westliche oder
chinesische zivilelektronik dies
betrifft das Radar Infrarotkameras
ultraviolette fotokatonen für die
raketenverfolgung digitale
Kommunikationssysteme und so weiter und
so fort deswegen müssen heute sowohl der
T14 als auch der T80 mit denselben
veralteten Optiken ausgestattet werden
die viel weniger fortschrittlich sind
als die die eigentlich für sie
vorgesehen waren denn was glaubt ihr
woher die meisten der fortschrittlichen
Wärmebildkameras und optischen Systeme
kam mit denen die Russen ihre Panzer
stolz ausgerüstet haben nun ja sie
stammen nicht aus Russland sondern aus
freien Ländern wie zum Beispiel Japan
oder Frankreich
[Musik]
laut geheimer Dokumente in deren besitzt
die französische investigative
journalistenorganisation des close
gekommen ist sollen die Unternehmen
Thales unserer Fragen die russische
Armee mit hochentwickelten westlichen
militärtechnologien beliefert haben dazu
gehört ein Optiken für mehr als 1.000
Panzer sowie Tarkan Navigationssysteme
für 60 zu Heu 30 Maschinen und
infrarot-detektoren für Kampfflugzeugen
Berichten zufolge haben sie auch
visuelles Systeme für camouf 52
Hubschrauber geliefert einige dieser
Technologien hätten französische
Unternehmen bis 2020 an Russland
geliefert also weit bis nach der
Invasion
2014 unter Umgebung der danach
verhängten Sanktionen gegen den
Aggressor ihr seht also es war nicht nur
das gierige Deutschland mit seiner
opportunistisch verantwortungslosen
Handelspolitik das Putin diesen Krieg
erst möglich gemacht hat auch Frankreich
hat ordentlich Dreck amstecken ja wie
sollen sich nur die vielen mit Hilfe
französischer Waffentechnologie
ermordeten ukrainischen Todesopfer und
ihre Hinterbliebenen in Paris bedanken
na was meint ihr
[Musik]
auf jeden Fall sind das nur ein paar
Beispiele aber die Realität ist das die
russische Militärindustrie sehr abhängig
von westlichen Komponenten aller Art war
und immer noch ist und zwar immer dann
sobald sie etwas mit einer
gewissentlichen logischen Komplexität
herstellen will
[Musik]
nach Angaben der britischen Denkfabrik
für Verteidigung und Sicherheit HOSI
stammen die Glasfaserkabel für die 300
mm Lenkraketen der Tornado s-rakete aus
den USA es gibt auch den Fall der
Militärfahrzeuge des Herstellers kammers
der die Produktion aller seiner modernen
militärplattformen einstellen musste
weil die Einspritzdüsen von Bosch
stammen sogar das russische
Luftabwehrsystem Tor m2 eines der
leistungsfähigsten Luftabwehrsystem mit
kurzer Reichweite hat britische
Komponenten die das radarplattform
Steuern das heißt wenn es um
einigermaßen ausgefalte Waffen geht in
irgendeiner Weise mit westlichen Waffen
konkurrieren können ist praktisch keine
davon zu 100% russisch praktisch alle
von ihnen haben mindestens eine
Schlüsselkomponente oder Technologie
Ausländern die sie jetzt nicht mehr
anbieten aber wir müssen gar nicht so
weit gehen auch scheinbar einfache Teile
wie Kugellager sind für die Russen
Kriegs wichtig und zwar so wie sie es
zum Beispiel schon seit dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg waren als die britische
Luftwaffe gezielt jagt auf Kugellager
Fabriken machte und wie ihr euch
vorstellen könnte das Russland dazu
Einheiten nicht mein ausreichender Menge
herstellen zu können oder zumindest nach
er Satz für diese Komponenten zu suchen
diese substitute sind jedoch wenn sie
nicht sowieso hoffnungslos veraltet sind
häufig viel weniger ausgereift
leistungsfähig und zuverlässig
was ist perfekt rund aus Metall und hält
Russland davon ab die 2000 Panzer zu
ersetzen die es in der Ukraine verloren
hat Optiken sind nicht das Einzige was
in der russischen panzerindustrie knapp
ist den Russen fehlen auch dringend
Kugellager die sie früher aus den USA
und Europa bezogen die offensichtlichen
Alternativen sind China und Malaysia
aber chinesische und malaysische
Kugellager sind in der Regel
minderwertiger als amerikanische oder
europäische Kugellager diese geringere
Qualität hat ihren Preis vielleicht
fährt Russland also irgendwann die
Panzer Produktion wieder hoch in dem es
gute Kugellager gegen minderwertige
austauscht da sie auch die moderne
digitale Optik gegen minderwertige
analoge Optik getauscht haben genügen
diese Panzer aber nicht mehr den
Qualitätsstandards sicher sie sehen
vielleicht aus wie T-72 PM3 oder t90m
aber im Inneren wo es wirklich darauf
ankommt sind sie weniger leistungsfähig
und weniger widerstandsfähig das alles
schreckt die ursprüngliche
Kampffähigkeit der meist sowieso schon
über spezifizierten Waffensysteme der
Russen also noch zusätzlich ein und
natürlich schwächt das letztlich Putins
Militär als Ganzes und zwar weit über
das Kriegsgerät an der Front hinaus es
führt auch zu einer Verkrüppelung der
genauso wichtigen Logistik denn nicht
nur gepanzerte Fahrzeuge brauchen eine
Menge Kugellager nein alle Fahrzeuge und
die russische Kriegsmaschine die ja die
gesamte russische Wirtschaft ist
vollständig vom Zugverkehr abhängig und
ausgerechnet Züge brauchen eine ganze
Menge Kugellager die Russen mussten sich
daher bereits entscheiden entweder mehr
Panzer bauen und das Eisenbahnsystem
zusammenbrechen lassen oder lieber die
Panzer Produktion verlangsamt sie haben
sich klugerweise für die zweite
Alternative entschieden und aus diesem
Grund reisten die Russen technologisch
gesehen in die Vergangenheit und
reaktivierten t262 aus den 60er Jahren
und T55 aus den 50er Jahren diese den
80er Jahren in den Lagern vor sich hin
gammeln diese älteren Panzer benötigen
nämlich weniger moderne Komponenten und
weniger Kugellager im Kampf mit den
besser ausgerüsteten ukrainischen
Streitkräften sie jedoch hoffnungslos
unterlegen aber sie verlangsamt die
Ukraine zumindest ein wenig diese sind
nämlich überraschenderweise noch bei
einer weiteren viel wichtigeren
Waffengattung erheblich im Vorteil der
Artillerie sie schaffen es nicht nur
ihre Ziele besser zu treffen sondern
auch dabei im Gegensatz zu den Russen
nur einen Bruchteil an Munition zu
verbrauchen dies erklärt auch die
krassen Unterschiede zwischen
ukrainischen und russischen Verlusten
und warum den Russen die Munition wohl
viel eher ausgehen dort obwohl sie
ursprünglich viel mehr davon hatten der
Artillerie Vorteile der Ukraine hat aber
nichts mit den Sanktion zu tun und auch
nicht unbedingt mit Heimat und Co wir
werden dieses Rätsel am Ende des Videos
aufklären ihr dürft aber schon mal
gespannt sein
insgesamt dürften durch die
internationalen Sanktionen den er als 30
Länder direkt betreffen die Importe nach
Russland bis 2022 um mehr als 40 Prozent
gesunken sein wohlgemerkt dabei werden
und die Sanktionen berücksichtigt die
nach dem 24 Februar 22 kamen vorher gab
es ja schon andere Sanktionen die nach
der Invasion auf der Creme und dem
donpass verhängt worden Sanktion die
eben hauptsächlich auf dem Kauf
militärischer Ausrüstung Nachschub
abzielten natürlich wurden gesehen haben
selbst von französischen Konzernen
gebrochen doch in der Praxis schenken
diese Sanktion natürlich schon los dann
Fähigkeiten ein so viele Waffen zu
produzieren und zu modernisieren wie es
für eine rechtzeitige Aufrüstung seiner
Streitkräfte gebraucht hätte russland
hatte z.B eine Vereinbarung mit
Frankreich über den Kauf von zwei
Mistral amphibienschiffen die nach der
Invasion in der Ukraine gekündigt wurde
aber abgesehen von den NATO Mitgliedern
haben auch andere Länder die keine
Sanktionen verhängt haben ihren Handel
mit Russland letzter Zeit freiwillig
reduzierten keine negativen Auswirkungen
auf ihre westlichen Märkte zu haben die
natürlich viel wichtiger sind als der
russische und das ist noch nicht alles
ganz und gar nicht es gibt noch einen
weiteren Grund dafür spricht das ist
Russland sehr schwer fallen dort Waffen
und Munition in dem Tempo zu produzieren
indem sie in diesem Krieg verbraucht und
das ist schlicht und einfach der
wirtschaftliche Faktoren
[Musik]
überlegt mal die militärischen
Fähigkeiten in einem Krieg aufrecht zu
erhalten der nun schon mehr als ein Jahr
andauern und dem sie praktisch allein
sind ohne Unterstützung von
irgendjemandem kostet eine Menge Geld
und ich meine wirklich eine Stange Geld
und es überrascht nicht dass ich dich
Sanktionen nicht gerade positiv auf die
russische Wirtschaft ausgewirkt haben
natürlich ist Krieg nicht billig und wir
dürfen nicht vergessen dass ich das pro
Kopf BIP Russland zu groß das Land auch
sein mag auf dem Niveau von Ländern wie
Argentinien oder Rumänien bewegt dabei
ist natürlich auch noch zu beachten dass
das russische BIP eben durch die
Militärausgaben stark verzerrt ist und
nicht die tatsächliche
Leistungsfähigkeit und vor allem
Zukunftsfähigkeit der russischen
Wirtschaft widerspiegelt obwohl die
offiziellen Zahlen über die waren Kosten
Invasion für Russland geheim sind dann
wird geschätzt dass der Militärhaushalt
im Jahr 2022 weit über 5% des
Bruttoinlandsprodukts und damit einen
Rekordwert erreichte den es seit der
Zeit nicht mehr gab man kann getrost von
mehr als 95 Milliarden Dollar ausgehen
was eine Überschreitung des 22er Budgets
von mehr als 40% entsprechend würde
hinzu kommt das der Krieg nicht zu kurz
geraten ist wie es der Kreml seine
strategischen Planer und Propagandisten
erwartet hatten er wird eben doch nicht
so billig wie die geplante drei Tage
blitzoperation mit anschließender
Militärparade auf den Kieler Maidan Teil
dieser wahnsinnigen wie verfehlten
Planung war auch eine gigantische
wirtschaftliche Wette Putin wollte mit
den Krieg die Energiepreise in die Höhe
treiben und gleichzeitig die Europäer
mit lieferkürzungen erpressen falls sie
zu sehr aufmucken auf diese Weise sollte
Europa aufgrund der dann extra bekannt
gestiegenen Margen nicht nur seine Krieg
finanzieren sondern auch noch
selbstverarbeitungen und den Kreml noch
einen ordentlichen die diesen Puffer
aufbauen so das künftige Feldzüge wie
z.B gegen wohl da wenn das Baltikum oder
Polen in greifbarer Nähe rücken würden
das war sozusagen Putins
Wunschvorstellung der Früchte Traum
eines Wahnsinnigen mega Mafioso und wenn
man zurückblickt wie die Stimmungslage
in den ersten Tagen der Invasion vor
allem auf den regierungskorrekturen in
Berlin und Paris war so weit hergeholt
war dieser Plan nicht schließlich hat
man ihn zuvor ja alles recht gut
durchgehen lassen Merkel hat es selbst
nach der Annexion der Krim Gastraum
einfach so die deutschen Gasspeicher
verkauft und die neue SPD-geführte
Regierung hat es nicht gejuckt das Putin
sie 2021 als Kriegsvorbereitung leer
gesaugt hat überhaupt diese tolle SPD
die hat sich sogar nicht gescheut in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern jede Menge krumme
machtschaften in Gang zu setzen um unter
dem Deckmantel einer Stiftung seinen
nordstring 2 Projekt willfährig
umzusetzen tja warum hätte sich Putin
denn in großsorgen machen müssen wenn
doch die zwei größten Wirtschaftsnation
der EU nichts von Abschreckungspolitik
gehört zu haben schienen und ihn quasi
ein luden einfach so weiter zu machen
wie es ihm gefiel zum Glück hat sich
diese miese Einstellungen wenn auch spät
so aber gehörig geändert allerdings
dürfen wir nicht vergessen dass die
Achse Berlin Paris ohne den massiven
Druck der eigenen Öffentlichkeit und
Partnerstaaten wie in den USA Polen
Finnland Tschechien und den Baltikum
Oliver weiterhin im piecement Modus
dahinter man würde dann diesen Drucks
konnte der Westen jedoch zu einer lange
ungewohnten Einigkeit zurück finden und
endlich wirksame Maßnahmen ergreifen vor
allem langfristig wirksame wir haben
bereits in einem vorigen Video über die
Wirksamkeit der Sanktion gegen Russland
erwähnt das für Putins Wirtschaft 2022
sozusagen noch ein karenzjahr war da die
Rohstoffpreise nach dem kriegsschock in
die Höhe geschossen und die Umstellung
der europäischen
Versorgungsinfrastruktur eben ein paar
Monate in Anspruch genommen hat im Jahr
2023 ist jedoch alles anders
im Grunde genommen haben die
Wirtschaftssanktionen wie zum Beispiel
das Ende der Gasimporte oder die
Preisobergrenze für russisches Öl einen
beträchtlichen Einfluss auf die
öffentlichen Finanzen Russlands nach
Angaben der russischen Regierung selbst
beliebt sich das föderale Defizit in den
ersten beiden Monaten des Jahres 23 auf
2,6 Billionen Rubel etwa 34,1 Milliarden
US-Dollar diese Zahl macht 88 % des
gesamten von der russischen Regierung
für 2023 prognostizierten Defizits aus
nachschätzungen auf economics und
meranisten wird das tatsächlich im Jahr
2023 3 bis 4 mal höher sein als 2022
beim derzeitigen Tempo wird die
Regierung den russischen nationalen
Investitionsfonds noch vor Ende des
Jahres vollständig aufgebraucht haben
und das ist der von der die
wirtschaftliche Leistungsfähigkeit der
Regierung Angesicht außergewöhnlicher
Situation sicherstellen sollte
außergewöhnlicher Situation wie in dem
Krieg gegen die Ukraine damit wir die
Verhältnisse nicht aus dem Auge
verlieren wir reden hier von einem
Notgroschen in Höhe von 150 Milliarden
Dollar Anfang 2023 der nur wenigen
Monaten aufgebraucht sein könnte und ab
diesem Zeitpunkt könnten sich dann
moskaust Probleme vervielfachen denn der
Kreml hätte im Grunde nur zwei
Möglichkeiten die Kriegsanstrengungen
weiter zu finanzieren entweder durch die
Emission von Staatsanleihen auf dem
lokalen Finanzmarkt was sowohl die
Zinssätze als auch des Defizit im
Staatshaushalt erhöhen würde oder er
monetarisiert die Schulden mit
zentralbankemissionen was eine Inflation
auslösen könnte Tatsache ist meine
Lieben Zuschauer dass die russischen
Staatseinnahmen aus dem Öl und Gas
verkauft zu Beginn des Jahres 2023 um
46% niedriger waren als im gleichen
Zeitraum 2022 und das ist noch nicht
alles auch die übrigen Einnahmen die
nicht mit Kohlenwasserstoffen zu tun
haben sind stark rückläufig die Dinge
laufen nicht gut
[Musik]
und diese Situation zwingt den Kreml
dazu die Finanzierung militärischer
Ausrüstung in die Budgets der Regionen
auszulagern mit anderen Worten die
lokalen und regionalen Regierungen haben
nicht nur anmacht verloren sondern auch
anderes Ressourcen da ein Teil ihres
Budgets nun für den Krieg ausgegeben
wird dies wird sich natürlich massiv auf
den Ausbau der sowieso schon desasten
Infrastruktur auswirken und somit auch
dezentralkräfte innerhalb der Föderation
Stärken Putin begeht also schon wieder
den ewigen Fehler des russischen
Imperialisten anstatt in jene Länder
rein zu investieren die die Russen
bereits haben sie so kultivieren und auf
Vordermann zu bringen verpulvern sie
ihre Ressourcen nur wieder darauf neues
Territorium zu erobern mir sowieso schon
überdehntes Riesenreich noch größer zu
machen ja Hauptsache noch mehr Land
erobern mehr mehr aber es sinnvoll
bewirtschaften das ist doch langweilig
und so wird ganz unabhängig davon ob
Putin den Krieg gegen die Ukraine noch
gewinnt oder nicht das sie tun das
flächenmäßig größte zweiten Landes der
Welt endlos weitergehen dabei hätte man
dieses Land uns ein Volk mit den
gigantischen Einnahmen aus den
Rohstoffexporten so weit voranbringen
können viele andere Länder haben es
vorgemacht stattdessen musste Putin den
russischen Karren schon wieder ganz tief
in den Dreck fahren wie eigentlich alle
seine Vorgänge um euch eine Vorstellung
davon zu geben die Ausgaben des
russischen Staates im Januar 2023 lagen
wegen des Krieges um 58% höher als im
gleichen Monat des Jahres 2022 und das
sind nur die offiziellen Daten
das Russland seine Wirtschaftszahlen
massiv frisiert und schön haben wir
schon in einen früheren Video dargelegt
vor allem ist das erste Anfang denn je
mehr finanzielle Klimmzüge der russische
Staaten noch unternehmen muss um seinen
Krieg zu finanzieren desto mehr
Schwierigkeiten wird in allen Ecken und
Enden bekommen daher haben
wirtschaftsaktionen in den Auswirkungen
die sie auf andere Bereiche wie
Infrastrukturen Lebensstandard haben
auch Auswirkungen auf die militärischen
Fähigkeiten wir würden euch jedoch nicht
die ganze Geschichte erzählen wenn wir
übersehen würden wie sich die russische
Rüstungsindustrie und der Staat selbst
an all diese Umstände angepasst haben
tatsache ist nämlich dass natürlich
jeder versucht Sanktion die gegen
einfach hängt werden zu umgehen und zu
kompensieren und das ist im Falle
auslassen natürlich nicht anders lass
uns deswegen doch mal lieber genau unter
die Lupe nehmen wie ihnen das gelingt
aufgepasst
[Musik]
Innovation zum Kill
eine für den Westen unbequeme Wahrheit
ist die russendemonstrieren das in der
Lage sind sich anzupassen und einige der
internationalen Sanktionen zu umgehen um
ihren verbrecherischen Feldzug in der
Ukraine fortsetzen zu können ich kann
euch aber schon jetzt sagen dass dies
keine langfristige wirksamenmaßnahmen
sind sondern nur ein Mittel um Zeit zu
finden denn Moskau erwirbt Chips und
andere hightech-bauteile die theoretisch
für zivile Zwecke bestimmt sind über
Länder die sich nicht an die Sanktionen
halten oder weniger strenge Sanktionen
haben die China Kasachstan oder die
Türkei über diese importkanäle gelingt
es ihnen jedoch viel weniger
technologische Produkte zu importieren
als früher auch wenn einige von ihnen im
westliche Komponenten enthalten zu denen
sie keine direkten Zugang mehr haben auf
jeden Fall können wir wirklich nicht
sagen dass sie Sanktion nicht wirken
würden denn aus allem was wir euch
gezeigt haben geht er vor dass die
russische Industrie weit von ihrem
Höhepunkt entfernt ist ich meine
produzieren sie ja die russische
Militärindustrie produziert aber viel
weniger moderne Ausrüstung als vor der
Invasion
die Beweise dafür dass Russland immer
noch Komponenten für die Herstellung
einiger fortschrittliche Waffen erhält
können dabei relativ einfach im Rahmen
der Analyse der durch sie in der Ukraine
verwendeten Waffen ermittelt werden so
hat die Analyse der Überreste einiger
russischer Präzisionsraketen vom Typ kha
101 die auf Kiew abgefeuert worden
ergeben dass sie zwischen September und
Oktober 2022 hergestellt worden mit
anderen Worten Russland ist in der Lage
weiterhin fortschrittliche Waffen
herzustellen wenn auch nicht in der
Quantität und Qualität die nötig wäre um
mit all den westlichen Waffen fertig zu
werden die in der Ukraine ankommen
darunter zum ersten Mal auch relativ
moderne Panzer wieder Leopard
um euch eine Vorstellung von nemar Roden
Zustand seiner Waffenlager zu geben
Russland verschießt mittlerweile vor
allem Raketen aus das Sowjet Ära und
viele von ihnen werden auch noch
zweckfremd eingesetzt das heißt es
kommen immer wieder viele Luftabwehr und
anti-schiffsgeschosse gegen Landziele
zum Einsatz mit drastischen Folgen für
ihre Präzision im Januar 2023 zum
Beispiel wurde ein Rakete die auf die
Stadt abgefeuert wurde analysiert und
stellte sich heraus dass es sich um eine
KH 22 handelte deren Produktion um 1962
begann und die furchtbar ungenau ist am
Ende traf sie sogar ein Wohnhaus und
tötete Dutzende von Menschen das
Wohngebäude nicht Provo wurde von einer
KH 22 Rakete getroffen die von der
ukrainischen Luft Abwehr nicht
abgeschossen werden kann es ist schon
verdammt traurig und ernüchtern das
Putin den viele vorher für einen
Mastermind gehalten haben nicht kapiert
das Präzision der Schlüssel für den Sieg
in diesem Krieg ist und das umgekehrt
jede russische Rakete auf ein ziviles
Ziel den Widerstand innerhalb der
ukrainischen Bevölkerung stärkt aber das
ist noch nicht alles ein weiteres
Beispiel für wie Russland versucht die
Sanktionen gegen seine militärischen
Fähigkeiten zu umgehen ist der Import
der berühmten iranischen Drohnen das war
jedoch nicht der einzige Fall sie haben
auch Panzer und gepanzerte Fahrzeuge aus
Weißrussland importiert und auch
Artilleriemunition aus Nordkorea auch
hierbei dürfte es sich nicht gerade um
die Creme de la Creme handeln also um
Waffen mit den in diesem Krieg
entscheidenden Eigenschaften präzise und
auf eine optimale Logistik ausgerichtet
minderwertige Munition ist jedoch nicht
das einzige Problem der russischen
Artillerie welche in diesem Krieg wohl
die wichtigste Waffengattung darstellen
dürfte die Artillerie der russischen
Armee krank nämlich ähnlich wie die
Panzerwaffe gleich an mehreren Punkten
und genau das könnte den Russen am Ende
das Genick brechen das Artillerie
paradox wie die Ukraine mit weniger
geschossen mehr Schaden anrichtet als
Russland wie in früheren großen
Konflikten ist auch in der Ukraine die
Artillerie der größte Killer auf dem
Schlachtfeld und für etwa 80% der Opfer
auf beiden Seiten verantwortlich aber
obwohl die Ukraine weniger Geschütze hat
und weniger Granaten abfeuert scheint
sie mehr Schaden anzurichten obwohl mit
einigen bemerkenswerten Ausnahmen die
gleichen Waffen wie die russischen
Gegner einsetzt doch wie ist dies
überhaupt möglich nun einige könnten
meinen dies hänge damit zusammen dass
Russland mehr offensiven durchführt
werden die Ukraine sich nur verteidigt
in letzter Zeit hat sich dies jedoch
geändert der Krieg ist weitgehend
statisch geworden russlandsvorteil bei
der Artillerie hätte sich daher gerade
jetzt in den Opferzahlen widerspiegeln
müssen es ist jedoch das genaue
Gegenteil der Fall die Russen sind auch
in diesem Fall einer kleineren Streit
macht unterlegen
die Lösung für dieses paradoxer liegt in
der unterschiedlichen Art und Weise wie
die beiden Armeen ihre Artillerie
einsetzen während Russland hauptsächlich
an der sowjetischen
Bombardements festhält muss die Ukraine
die Artillerie als scharfschützenwaffe
mit großer Reichweite um einzelne Ziele
auszuschalten möglich wurde dies durch
den weit verbreiteten Einsatz von zwei
Innovationen kleine Drohnen für die
Artillerie Aufklärung und billige
Tablet-Computer mit feuerleiste Software
wie dem nettesystem David Helmling Autor
und Berater für Verteidigungs
Technologie die ukrainische
gegenorganisation Army SOS startete die
Entwicklung des nettal-systems bereits
2014 gleich nach den ersten Überfall
Russlands auf die Ukraine es kann
absolut sicher kommunizieren und ist
nato-system kompatibel es wurde speziell
für die Arbeit mit kleinen billigen
Drohnen entwickelt empfängt deren Daten
und berechnet daraus alle Zielangaben
für den artillerieschützen damit dieser
das Ziel präzise und mit einem Minimum
an Munition ausschalten kann früher
konnte ein Fahrzeug vor allem wenn es
eingegraben oder getan oder dahinter
Gebäuden oder Bäumen versteckt war erst
entdeckt werden wenn die feindlichen
Kräfte in der Nähe waren mit der Drohnen
Vorhut ändert sich aber alles
kleine Drohnen können alles in Echtzeit
beobachten nicht nur Fahrzeuge sondern
sogar einzelne Soldaten es hilft nicht
mehr sich hinter einem bergkam oder
Hügel zu verstecken das fortschrittliche
Software und Kommunikationssystem Nettel
ordnet anhand dieser Daten jedes
potenzielle Ziel auf den Zentimeter
genau und gibt die Koordinaten an die
Artillerie weiter um die
Verteidigungsstellung eines russischen
standardtrupps auszuschalten während
normalerweise 60 bis 90 Artillerie
geschossen notwendig mit nette konnte
dieser durchschnittliche
Munitionsverbrauch jedoch effektiv auf
nur neuen Geschosse reduziert werden das
entspricht einem Einsparpotential mit
einem Faktor von 7 bis 10 was in etwa
auch dem Verhältnis von Artillerie
Granaten zu opfern entspricht wenn man
nun also bedenkt dass 80% aller Verluste
auf Artillerie Beschuss zurückzuführen
sind machen die in den Medien
kursierenden krassen Unterschiede
zwischen ukrainischen und russischen
Verlustzahlen durchaus Sinn und diese
Ansatz ist nicht auf traditionelle
Artillerie beschränkt auch ukrainische
Panzer können so ungestützt auf
gegnerische Panzer feiern welche sie
sich außerhalb deren sich Reichweite
befinden
folgende Video zum Beispiel dokumentiert
den möglicherweise längsten Panzer zu
panzerkill aller Zeiten hierbei gelang
es an der ukrainischen tief 64 BV
Panzerbesatzung einen russischen Panzer
aus einer Entfernung von über 10 km im
indirekten Feuermodus mit 125 mm
fahrgeschossen zu zerstören der
russische Panzer hatte dabei keinerlei
Chance denn er konnte seinen Gegner noch
nicht einmal sehen wohlgemerkt dieser
Gegner war auch ein Panzer keine
Artillerie ja so sieht's aus auch im
Vergleich der Kampfkraft von Armenien
sind nackte Zahlen nur wenig
aussagekräftig worauf es ankommt sind
Strukturen und Details und wie wir
gesehen haben sind deswegen die
Herausforderungen der russischen Armee
gewaltig aber gut auch in diesem Video
konnten wir nur über einen Teil der
Probleme sprechen mit denen das
russische Militär zu kämpfen hat und ja
ich weiß dass es noch viel zu klären
gibt Mobilisierung Ausrüstung an der
Frauen und Ausbildung von
Unteroffizieren
befehlstaktionsauftragstaktik und
natürlich Logistik Logistik und nochmals
Logistik aber keine Angst all das werden
wir in künftigen Videos noch
auseinandernehmen
abonniert also bitte unseren Kanal und
aktiviert auch unbedingt das Glöckchen
wenn sie euch genauso interessieren wie
uns gegen Ende will ich euch aber noch
eines nicht vorenthalten und zwar unser
Fazit was können wir jetzt aus den
Erfahrungen von mehr als einem Jahr
Krieg und all den Sanktion gegen
Russland lernen nun die übergeordnete
Lektion ist vor allem diese
[Musik]
Sanktion als einziges Mittel reichen
nicht aus um Moskau zu zermürben denn
ihre Wirkung wird vor allem mittel und
langfristig eintreten ohne ständige
militärische Unterstützung für die
Ukraine in Form von Waffenlieferungen
Ausbildung während sie wirklich nutzlos
denn wie gesagt der Russe ist
anpassungsfähig und hält vieles aus er
ist in der Lage wirklich dumme
Strategien und Taktiken endlose weiter
zu verfolgen bis alle seine Ressourcen
aufgereben sind bzw er physisch gestoppt
wird wenn die Ukraine nicht die Kraft
hätten die Kosten für Russland an der
Front zu vervielfachen nicht nur ein
Menschenleben sondern vor allem an
Waffen dann hätte Moskau wahrscheinlich
nicht so viele Probleme seinen Feldzug
auszuweiten dies wäre dann eine enorme
Gefahr für Europa und natürlich würde es
auch die Ukraine weiter zum Würgen deren
Militär Ausgaben im Jahr 2022 machen
nach Angaben der ukrainischen Regierung
etwa
32,5% ihres BIP aus schafft es die
Ukraine jedoch mit der geballten
Unterstützung ihrer westlichen
Verbündeten und aufgrund ihrer
zahlreichen Vorteile bzw Nachteile der
Russen die Militärmaschine die Putin
irgendwann zu erschöpfen und auch zu
reiben so ist nicht nur die perspekt
eröffnet für die Rückeroberung alle
ihrer besetzten Gebiete nein dann könnte
auch der Weg zur Demilitarisierung und
schließlich auch zur nuklearen
Entwaffnung des zurzeit größten
streckenspenstes und aggresshaus der
Welt eröffnet sein auf das Russland
eines Tages dann ebenso friedlichen wie
prosperierenden und zufriedenen Landwirt
wie die einstigen kriegsreiber
Deutschland und Japan und auf das von
russischen Boden nie wieder ein Krieg
ausgehen kann so wie auch nicht von
deutschem oder japanischen wir werden
auf jeden Fall an dieser Entwicklung
dran bleiben und bis dahin seid ihr
jetzt erstmal ihr wieder an der Reihe
glaubt ihr dass die Sanktion gegen
Russland nach allem was wir gesehen
haben auf militärischen Gebiet Wirkung
zeigen sollten wir die Waffenlieferungen
an die Ukraine noch weiter erhöhen um
die russische zu Vermehrung zu
beschleunigen welche Waffen sollten
eurer Meinung nach versteckt geliefert
werden wie immer sind wir auf eure
Diskussion zu diesem Thema schon mächtig
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
Video gefallen hat mir vielleicht auch
was dabei gelernt habt falls ja gibt uns
bitte ein Like heißt mit euren Freunden
und fragt sie dann nach deren Meinung
dazu natürlich wollen wir uns jederzeit
über eine Spende von euch mit uns dieses
Projekt weiterzuführen den Link dazu
findet ihr in der Beschreibung unter dem
Video macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]